I can't believe we have to explain this
again in America and 2015 but let's talk
about free speech for a second because
people seem to be very confused in
America we have something called the
First Amendment and the First Amendment
guarantees the right to free speech that
means you can say whatever you want
even if it is offensive that means we
have freedom of expression so you can
express yourself freely again even if
it's offensive I can wear this shirt
which many people have told me is quite
offensive they don't like this shirt but
I'm allowed to wear it and I am
expressing myself you're not allowed to
shoot me because of it
so now I want to show you something
since cartoons seem to make people angry
and offended and shoot people and it
seems to make other people then blame
the victims who are getting shot for
expressing their free speech so let's
watch a clip from a popular television
show called Family Guy oh oh
fascinating madness Jesus must have been
I can just imagine meeting you
that clip might be construed to
Christians as offensive that is their
Savior their Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ sensually bathing in front of a
baby
yeah they might think that's offensive
and guess what Family Guy offends
everybody Mort Goldman the Jewish
character on family is the worst of
every Jewish stereotype there is they
make fun of black people people with
AIDS mentally challenged people
handicapped people these are all highly
offensive things that these groups small
groups of people actually could get
offended by and you know what it's okay
and these people don't shoot anybody
because that's not how it works you
cannot shoot people because your free
speech because you don't like someone
else's free speech everyone needs to get
on that there is no excuse you can't
accept you can't give an exception to
one group everybody has to accept this
that's how the country works that's how
the country needs to go forward once you
excuse one group and say all right well
we can sort of figure out why they are
offended by this so we shouldn't do that
well then everyone has a right to do it
and again guess what
free speech goes completely right out
the window